[Music]
hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar discovering the fda-cleared
acuitous amr gene panel building a case
for clinical utility
i am marie stone of labyrinths and i'll
be your moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by lab roots and brought to
you by opgen
to learn more visit upgen.com
we encourage you to participate today by
submitting any questions you may have
during the presentation
to do so simply type them into the ask a
question box and click send
we'll answer as many questions as we
have time for at the end of the
presentation
you may also submit any technical issues
here as well if you have trouble seeing
or hearing the presentation
this webinar is educational and thus
offers free continuing education credits
please click on the continuing education
window at the bottom of your screen to
obtain your credits
i'd like to now welcome our speakers dr
stephen riedel associate medical
director clinical microbiology
laboratories at best israel deaconess
medical center and associate professor
of pathology at harvard medical school
and dr trish simner associate professor
of pathology john hopkins university
school of medicine and director of the
medical bacteriology and infectious
disease sequencing laboratories johns
hopkins hospital
dr riedel and dr simner you may now
begin your presentation
thank you for the kind introduction
today dr simner and i will present on
the fda cleared the futures amr panel
and its potential clinical utility
listed here are dr simners and my
various disclosures regarding today's
presentation
the learning objectives are the
following
we will first describe the fda clear the
futures amr piano then define the
performance characteristics of the
impurities amr panel
and then discover the potential utility
of the accuratus amr panel to impact
patient care
but first let's begin with a brief
perspective on the era of antibiotics
since their initial discovery
antibiotics have been major pillars of
modern medicine and not only allowed for
pure previously untreatable infectious
diseases but also contributed to major
advances in various other areas of
medicine and surgery
however the antibiotic era has been
rather short compared to the long time
that bacteria and other microorganisms
have been around many antibiotics that
were discovered in the past are actually
produced by various microorganisms and
therefore it should be appreciated that
antimicrobial resistance genes have also
been around for an equally long time
although antimicrobial resistance is not
a new phenomenon resistance rates have
been increasing during the last three
decades at an unprecedented rate
using the iceberg analogy it has become
clear over the past decades that there
was is and continues to be a lot more to
learn and understand about antimicrobial
resistance development
amr is a complex and dynamic issue
involving aspects of intrinsic
resistance resistance in environmental
bacteria and sharing of resistant
streams among various bacterial
pathogens
i want to draw your attention to the
fact that it is now ever more so
appreciated that the various ways human
societies utilize antibiotics however
have been major contributing factors to
the emergence and spread of
antimicrobial resistance
while antimicrobial resistance was
recognized almost immediately at or
around the time of discovery of
antibiotics and the using clinical
patient here during the beginnings of
the antibiotic era some 80 years ago
the problem of amr has only come to
center stage some 25 years ago
today an estimated 235 million doses of
antibiotics are consumed in the united
states
at the same time more than 2.8 million
infections due to antibiotic resistant
organisms with more than 35 000 deaths
are recorded in the us annually
globally the problem is even bigger with
almost 1 million deaths due to amr
infections
nothing changes it is estimated that by
2050 the mortality due to infectious
diseases with resistant organisms will
surpass the mortality due to cancer and
many other diseases
the 2019 cdc amr threat report further
highlights this problem despite the
improvements due to preventative
measures such as antimicrobial
stewardship programs and other
interventions since the 2013 threat
assessment report
increases in various infection types and
especially amr organisms have been noted
as you see the cdc especially highlights
the threat due to espl producing
anthrobacteriales
mdr pseudomonas erogenosa and
copperpenem-resistant anthrobacteralis
in this latest report
amr has a significant impact not only on
an individual patient's health
but has an impact on the overall health
system
many studies have investigated
and highlighted the impact on length of
stay on the economic burden as listed
here on the slide
while antimicrobial stewardship programs
as required by cms for u.s hospitals
participating in the medicare medicaid
programs are helpful in mitigating the
amr problem in some healthcare setting
sorry in some healthcare settings rates
of amr infections continue to increase
again having a significant health
economic impact given the fact that
infections due to amr pathogens are
associated with longer hospital lengths
of state
the question to ask here now is how
improvements in diagnostic laboratory
testing methods could contribute to
solutions for the amr problem
in this respect we can readily identify
certain patient populations that would
clearly benefit from utilizing rapid amr
tests
such patients include the
immunocompromised oncology and organ
transplantations as they are at higher
risk of developing infections due to amr
pathogens
now listed here are the current and
standard approaches that laboratories
may use for antimicrobial susceptibility
testing while many of these test methods
have been around for decades they have
been proven to be useful and
laboratories and clinicians alike are
very familiar with the performance
characteristics of such methods
please note however that all of these
methods are inevitably based on organism
growth and exposure to a specific
antimicrobial agent
in the past time these culture-based
phenotypic susceptibility test methods
are still the predominant and routine
methods in most laboratories in the u.s
in fact some of the oldest methods such
as the broth micro dilution testing are
considered to be a reference method or
what we call a gold standard furthermore
regulatory agencies such as the fda clsi
and ucas have established standards for
guidelines for ast performance and
interpretation of the results again
laboratories and clinicians alike are
very familiar with these guidelines for
daily use in their clinical practice
however the turnaround time results by
these methods are often rather lengthy
depending on an individual individual's
laboratory's workflow
ast results are typically available
anywhere between 36 and 72 hours after a
patient's specimen has been received for
culture and testing
during the past decades great progress
has been made to develop rapid
diagnostic methods
these include methods for rapid organism
ids such as moldy top
or panel-based id and ast molecular
tests often used directly from primary
patient specimens such as such as the
biofire the verigene system e-plex or
cepheid expert test systems
these are all shown on this slide
numerous studies during the past decades
have also demonstrated that rapid
organism identification is indeed
helpful in conjunction with
antimicrobial stewardship programs to
implement more judicious use of
antibiotics
this study highlighted here on this
slide shows
that such impact has been readily seen
with infections due to gram-positive
organisms and reduction of unnecessary
use of angomycin for example however
infections due to gram-negative bacteria
continue to be a challenge
even with the use of currently available
multiplex pcr tests
rapid organism identification coupled
with testing for a few selected
resistance genes followed by standard
phenotypic susceptibility testing is an
approach taken by many laboratories
today to support the clinical approach
to treating infectious diseases from
empiric therapy
we targeted antibiotic therapy
now the majority of these current test
methods share some of the same narrow
selection of resistance genes listed on
the left side of the slide
however these test methods do not offer
a comprehensive antimicrobial
susceptibility profile and many of these
tests are typically performed on primary
patient specimens therefore requiring
dedicated panels for each type of
specimen or sample
and lastly none of these tests directly
link the identified amr marker or gene
to the organism that has been detected
while the gap between specimen
submission and organism identification
has now been shortened the turnaround
time for susceptibility test results has
not changed
and therefore often widens the
turnaround time gap between organism id
and the final phenotypic susceptibility
test results
so the question today is what would
change if a molecular more comprehensive
test method with a reasonably shorter
turnaround time was available to detect
multiple amr genes and how would this
test impact patient care
i would now like to turn it over to dr
simner to describe and discuss the
acuitous amrt panel
thank you dr riedel uh thank you for
going over the problem which is that of
antimicrobial resistance this global
public health threat
and describing some of the solutions
that whether that be rapid diagnostics
to help us address
antimicrobial stewardship or infection
control initiatives
one of those rapid diagnostics that was
recently fda cleared is the cutis amr
gene panel so what is this panel
what effect does it have on patient care
or the potential effect on patient care
and what are its
performance characteristics so i will
attempt to achieve that in the remainder
of this presentation
so the cutis amr gene panel is a
multiplex real-time pcr assay for the
detection and differentiation of 28
antimicrobial resistance markers which
can be associated with not susceptible
antimicrobial susceptibility results up
to nine
antimicrobial classes or subclasses
so you'll see here in the table the list
of antimicrobial agents and the
antibiotics that can be associated with
those particular agents the association
will vary based off of the organisms
being tested and so what do we
test on this panel well we perform the
panel on isolated colonies these
colonies can be from blood agar or
mcconkey hagar and can be from
enterobacteralis pseudomonas originosa
or enterococcus specalis
so i want to point out here two unique
items about the cutis amr gene panel
it's one of the broadest or it is the
broadest fda cleared amr panel now with
up to 28 antimicrobial resistance genes
that tests a broader spectrum of
beta-lactamase genes but also resistance
genes to associate to resistance to
aminoglycosides fluoroquinolones and
trimethoprim alpha methoxazole
and the second point is that you're that
we're able to associate those resistance
genes with uh
not susceptible resist uh results to to
help us with determining appropriate
therapy so addressing our stewardship or
even detecting those amr genes to
detect
infection to help with infection control
initiatives
so what is the workflow for the cutis
amr gene panel well the cutis panel is
really these
provides 96 well plate panels for which
the 96 wall for which the multiplex pcr
is performed but first you'll take your
extract from your or you'll take your
isolate of interest and you'll extract
it extract it on the kyogen easy one
system
that you'll then take the extract and
the master mix provided by the kit and
add that
to the first three columns of your pcr
96 well pcr plate and you can see here
in the image that you could test up to
four isolates per panel
on a single 96 well plate
you'll then centrifuge that fill the
plate up with your four organisms seal
it centrifuge it and place it on the
quant studio 5 real-time pcr system
where a pcr protocol is run for 45
minutes you'll then take the results
from there upload it to the option
analysis software which will generate a
report so from sample from the beginning
to the end it's 2.5 hour turnaround time
with approximately 30 minutes hands-on
time so this is a semi-automated method
it's not a sample to answer approach but
it has removed a lot of
the manual steps through automation but
still
involves some user interaction
so what do the
reports look like for the cutest amr
gene panel well the first
page of the report outlines the agents
the amr genes as listed as detected or
not detected and this is based off of
the id that's selected in the drop down
menu so based off of the organism
identification it will reflect the
results appropriate for that
identification
and then on the second page it will
summarize
at the top in the table it lists the on
panel genes that are associated with the
not susceptible agents for that
particular drug bug combination and at
the bottom in the last table it lists
the agents on the panel that are either
not associated or not reportable for
that particular organism that you chose
in the drop down menu
so the the next question is is uh where
does this fit in to the current
diagnostic
spectrum
and so uh our standard methodologies
allow us
to detect to provide id and
identification and susceptibility
testing results within about two to
three days as dr riedel pointed out in
his initial slides we've luckily over
the last 10 decades had many new toys or
diagnostic tools
that have been helped us help us to more
rapidly detect antimicrobial resistance
these can be anything from simplex or
multiplex molecular panels performed
direct from specimens
to the next day from the recovered
isolate where you could provide a rapid
maldi id but also perform additional
testing to define antimicrobial
resistance like the pbp2a for detection
of methicillin resistant staph aureus
alternatively chromogenic agars can be
helpful based off of the antimicrobial
agents in the media media to select for
vre or carbapenem-resistant organisms
you could also use targeted pcrs from
cultured isolates but on the flip side
we're seeing some more advanced
diagnostics being introduced like whole
genome sequencing which is gaining
traction but it is still very um manual
requires a lot of expertise it's manual
both from a molecular expertise
standpoint but also from a
bioinformatics expertise standpoint but
it really is something that we look
forward to in the clinical microbiology
lab
there's also the accelerate pheno system
which is a rapid phenotypic ast method
that could be performed from positive
blood cultures that provides rapid id
and ast within seven and a half hours
from a positive blood culture this is
where the cutest amr gene panel fits in
in terms of comparator in terms of time
[Music]
time to result and where it would be
performed so you would be isolating your
organism id and then maybe in parallel
or after that id is obtained from maldi
you would move forward with the acuteist
amr gene panel to provide results within
two and a half hours
post multi id
and then further down the line if you do
your standard ast some additional
testing may be required
uh to define mechanisms a resistance
like the uh
the carbon np are the modified uh
carbopenemon activation method that can
help define whether a
carbopenem-resistant organism is due to
carbopentamine production or not
so what is the performance
characteristics of the cutis amr gene
panel
well this was evaluated through a
multi-center study
for fda clearance of the assay so this
is the data presented here is the data
that was submitted to the fda for fd for
clearance uh for 510k clearance of this
assay the publication was submitted to
the journal of clinical microbiology
and the purpose of this study was to
establish the
performance characteristics of the cutis
amr gene panel compared to a combined
reference standard um
and i'll go over that combined reference
standard in a second
but the overall study um involved four
different geographically diverse sites
which included cleveland clinic at johns
hopkins uh wadsworth center as well as
ihma
and isolates were chosen to be included
in the study based off a previous site
being previously being identified as one
of the panel targets organisms um not
targets but organisms that are able to
be tested such as centrobacteralis
pseudomonas originosa or enterococcus
cicalis a total of 1300 isolates were
tested across these sites with 1200
retrospective isolates and 83
prospective isolates the comparator to
the cutis amr gene panel was the whole
was whole genome sequencing for the
detection of amr genes with an endpoint
of approximately with a a primary
endpoint for amr markers of 95 positive
percent and negative percent agreement
and then from the prediction or the not
prediction but association of
antimicrobial susceptibility results um
standard phenotypic uh broth micro
dilution methods were the comparator
where for a marker to be associated with
a not susceptible result it had to meet
both criterias of at least 95 positive
percent and negative percent agreement
for detection of an amr marker but also
to meet uh and at least
meet and surpass a great 80 positive
predictive value for correlation to that
phenotypic not susceptible result
so the clinical performance and
comparative in comparison to whole
genome sequencing for detection of the
amr markets markers by reportable gene
range from 94.4 percent to 100
uh for ppa for positive percent
agreement and 96.5 to 100 for negative
percent agreement
initially um 31 amr markers were
submitted to the fda but only 28 are
included in the final fda version and
you'll notice here that the endpoint of
95 is a little bit lower here down to
94.4
this is uh because the fda
decided to clear mcr1
at a slightly lower level of 94.4
percent uh ppa
and then in addition um based off so for
each organism um claimed organism that
can be performed on this panel the the
based off of the species level um data
the reportable amr markers varies based
off of the species so it could be
anywhere from one amr marker being
reported such as enterococcus vicalis
and dna or the providentia species in
ndm all the way up to a more expanded
spectrum of amr genes reported for some
of the more common gram negatives that
we encounter like e coli klebsiella
pneumoniae proteus mirabilis and
pseudomonas originosa
so any discrepant results that were
encountered between whole genome
sequencing and the cutis amr panel were
divided into two groups one was uh just
due to sample air or mix-up or different
organism identifications were obtained
or inconsistent results on sample
replicates
were obtained and so those results
were resulted in some discrepancies but
there are also some amr gene level
discrepancies such as variants that
didn't have valid alignments with the
primer and probes or the presence of
truncated genes that could result in a
false positive by the acute samar
or a high number of
primer
mismatches resulting in false negatives
where the primer probes did not pick up
particular variants however there were
so few of these and the impact of
discrepant analysis would not have
impacted the results that um this was
not pursued in this study
so the last part of the cuitis amr panel
is the and the most exciting part is the
ability to not only detect amr genes but
also associate that that gene with the
with um
with not susceptible results so
intermediate or resistant results to
particular agents so what do i mean by
that what i mean is that if you detect a
resistance gene the the the probability
that organism carrying a resistant
marker being not
susceptible to the expected agent is at
least 80
i must note here that the phoenix that
this does not replace phenotypic ast and
that this is an adjunct to
traditional or conventional methods
and that this method is associating the
detection of a resistance gene
with the probability of
not susceptible results to those agents
identified
but they are not predictive in terms of
the the absence predicts susceptibility
versus the presence predicts resistance
so there is a difference there and
should be noted
so in conclusion this study
found that the cutis amar gene panel is
an accurate method to detect a broad
array of amr markers among cultured
isolates the amr markers were further
associated with expected not susceptible
results for specific agent organism
combination
and these associated agents included
many include many of the most commonly
prescribed antimicrobial agents
including beta lactams fluoroquinolones
trimethoprim sulfamethoxazole and
aminoglycosides
these results have the potential to
guide patient care at least a day
earlier than conventional phenotypic ast
methods and can be applied to support
stewardship and infection control
programs but that leaves us with the
ultimate question is what is the
clinical utility of this diagnostic for
patient care and so so dr riedel and i
are going to try to address this through
three hypothetical cases and i'll start
us off with case one so this is a case
of a 23 year old otherwise healthy male
who underwent surgery for appendicitis
he developed sepsis in the
post-operative period he was febrile
hypotensive and tachycardic so blood
cultures were collected and the patient
was empirically started on ceftraxone
and metronidazole where the ceftraxone
allows for broad ground negative and
streptococcal coverage and the
metronidazole allows for intestinal
anaerobic coverage
so the blood culture for this patient
signaled positive at approximately 16
hours there was growth in both aerobic
and anaerobic bottles and the gram stain
revealed a gram-negative bacilli
we have a rapid molecular pcr uh panel
from positive blood cultures we
performed the genmark panel at our
institution which was able to detect e
coli from the positive blood culture
broth uh quite rapidly within a couple
hours of its signaling positive and we
were able to say not only is the
sacrament negative basal bacilli
but this is e coli specifically the
important point here is that in this
case it did not detect any of the amr
markers on that panel which includes the
escl ctxm and the big five
carbopenemases kpc ndm vim imp and
oxalic enzymes and so in this case in
the case at our institution we do not
report out the absence of those markers
so on the following day our cultures
were consistent with the lactose
fermenting gram-negative bacilli
that was further ideally by maldi as e
coli consistent with the molecular panel
so what if we could have had the cutest
amr gene panel in this patient case
if we did we would have identified this
cmi producing e coli
that is an amp c beta lactamase
producing e coli that also harbored
antimicrobial agents that are associated
with not susceptible results to the
aminoglycosides so gentamicin topomyces
it also harbored a jar a mutant
mutation resulting in
associated with not susceptible results
to the fluoroquinolones and then also
harvard saw genes associated with
trimethyl from sulfamethoxazole
not susceptible results
so before i get into the impact of these
results in this particular patient case
what is cmy so mc cmy is an c beta
lactamase fancy beta lactamase can be
broken down into inducible antsy
producers like the spice organisms or
non-inducible chromosomal ampsi uh
producers
ampsi producers that like e coli or
atonitobacter where they usually produce
this at very low levels and we do not
see uh the effect of this on their
ast profiles unless there's mutations in
the promoter or a tenure
attenuator region of the gene resulting
in a high level expression but the third
is plasma mediated mc and cmy is one of
those plasma mediated axes as well as
dha
which is another target on the acutus
amr panel so what does what does that
matter well the the cmy gene uh so it's
plasma mediated so it's not species
specific unlike the chromosomal genes
that you know specific organisms that
may harbor it and these genes are not
for the most part are non-inducible so
they're all already be being expressed
at high levels resulting in the ampsi
phenotype of resistance to penicillins
narrow extended spectrum cephalosporins
cephamycins monobactams and sometimes
for priscilla and tazobactam they're
inhibited by cloxicillin and boronic
acid however they we don't detect these
on a standard basis clinically
clsi doesn't have any endorsed methods
the european committee does describe an
algorithm to detect acquired or plasmid
and c among known organisms lacking
chromosomal at c
um but not this isn't really standard
practice although many ruo phenotypic
and genotypic methods have been
described such as the uh disk test
demonstrated in the bottom uh right hand
corner here
what about the molecular side do you
what about the currently available or
forthcoming molecular panels do they
have
plasma deviated amp c genes
um so there are none as of yet except
for the optin acutus amr gene panel that
contains uh plasma media to mc and as i
pointed out
cmy and dha are the two on the acutus
amr panel there are some forthcoming
like the t2 resistance panel that will
also be um we'll also have these targets
that can be performed direct from whole
blood
so why does it matter why is it
important to detect cmy well treatment
guidance based on whether mechanism
testing are performed is now
is now being described by the idsa and
recommended treatment will differ based
off of the mechanism mediating
resistance and for espl and app c
producers this is um important because
phenotypically it could be hard to
distinguish the two of them from each
other and so but the recommended therapy
for an espl is maripenum for um
for um
for invasive or serious infections
whereas cefeme is the treatment of
choice for amp c betalactamases so it's
not only important to understand the
phenotype but the mechanism is also
important for guiding therapy
so what could have been the particular
impact in this specific case well
detection of cmi would help us to uh
tailor therapy so the
idsa treatment guideline suggests
avoiding ceftraxone for treatment of nfc
producing entropectoralis and if you
recall our patient was started
empirically on ceftraxone so the
detection of cmi would allow the
clinical team to tailor therapy to the
treatment of choice of cefepine based
off of the detection of cmy
and then detection of the other
antimicrobial resistant genes like the
fluoroquinolone and the trimethoprim
sulfamethoxazole resistant genes
could help
give guidance to the team about the
potential of these not being effective
as oral step down therapy in this
particular case
due to the severity of this patient's
illness they would likely wait until the
phenotypic ast results uh to pro to
guide oral step down therapy in this
particular case but knowing that there
is fluoroquinolone resistance mechanisms
as well as trimethoprim sulfur
resistance mechanisms
is certainly helpful in this particular
case and would really um encourage the
team to wait until the phenotypic asts
to guide that step down therapy
alternatively if we could have had
another case where there is a patient
with pyloritis who often improve after a
dose of iv therapy in the ed
oftentimes the clinical team because
they improve so quickly
they often discharge the patient on
oral therapy
quite rapidly
it might not have the time or the
privilege to be able to keep the patient
in the hospital prior to discharge and
so these
rapid amr results and let's say a
similar cmi case
could help
potentially guide that oral step down
therapy
if they want to discharge that patient a
little bit earlier from an infection
control standpoint these results can be
helpful as well as i mentioned it's not
standard practice to detect plasma
immediate mc for patient care they
really usually go undetected currently
by standard methods so
however they have similar risk to espl
producers if we think about it they're
plasma mediated they're easily
transmissible and they're often
multi-drug resistant so knowing a
patient harbors an infection with a
plasma mediated empty producing organism
can be helpful for infection control
purposes and may require patients to be
on contact precautions
so in summary the cutest amr
how did the cutest amr result
potentially could have potentially
impacted this case well our patient was
started empirically on ceftriaxone and
metronidazole
the initial ground stain and
nat results of e coli could have helped
the team discontinue metronidazole at
that point knowing that they were
dealing with an aerobic gram-negative or
facultative anaerobic from negative
organism where metronidazole was no
longer required
the cutest amr gene panel results could
have helped transition the patient from
uh ceftraxone which is not recommended
for amsci producers to the treatment of
choice acefete
and then the detection of the additional
amr markers would have
likely has had the the team want to wait
for those phenotypic ast results to uh
ultimately guide that oral uh step down
therapy in this case
so i'm gonna pass it over to dr riedel
for case number two
let's take a look at another case
case two is a 72 year old female patient
who was transferred from a long-term
care facility to the emergency
department because of a loss of smell
and taste on the prior day followed by
rapid onset of fever and a headache and
now with additional slightly altered
mental status
the idea molecular test for saskov2 was
performed and was positive
because of worsening pulmonary function
the patient was transferred to the icu
and eventually intubated and ventilated
the chest radiographic imaging showed
perchie infiltrates in the right lower
lobe and left lower lobe at this point
consistent with cobit 19 viral pneumonia
on day four of hospitalization the
clinical status of the patient worsened
and a ventilator associated with
pneumonia was suspected based on the
various findings listed here on the
slide
the vamp protocol was initiated and the
bronchoalvial laboratory was performed
and submitted for culture
the patient was started empirically on
vancomycin paper cylinder bacterium and
tobramycin
on day one two different gram-negative
bacilli were identified on the primary
arga media these organisms were then
subcultured to allow for further
identification and on day two the
organisms were identified as clefcilla
cascala pneumoniae and enterobacter
chloe
what if we had used the acuratus amr
gene panel at this time for these two
isolates
for the klebsiella pneumoniae the panel
would have detected the kpc gene the tam
gene and the sul1 and salt 2 genes
associated resistance to respective
antibiotic agents are listed on the
slide illustrating the necessity at that
point for change of the current empiric
therapy
and eliminating cover patterns as a
treatment option
similarly the acute's amr gene panel
would have been used for the androbacter
chlorachia isolate and what has detected
the temp gene as well
please keep in mind that enterobacter
chloeki has intrinsic resistance to the
antimicrobial agents listed here
while the tam gene also precludes
piprocilantazobactem as a treatment
option kpc was not detected
before i will address the impact that
this testing might have had on this
patient's care i would briefly like to
review some information about
carbopanomasis
garbapanamasas represent the most
versatile family of beta-lactamases
they belong to two major statements two
major molecular families
distinguished
by the hydrolytic mechanism at the
active site the class a and d copper
panamasis belong to the serine
beta-lactamase group and the class b
are metallovated nectamases
some colourpanameses are chromosomally
encoded while many others such as kpc
and ldema plasmid-mediated and therefore
highly transmissible
furthermore it is important to realize
that enzymatic hydrolysis due to
carbopanomasis is not the only
mechanisms of mechanism of resistance
other mechanisms
include loss of expression of poor
encoding genes or efflux pump mechanisms
as an example
detection of carbapanama's producing
organisms is important for clinical
patient care and selection of the most
appropriate antimicrobial therapy
currently carbon resistant
enterobacterialis account for more than
13 000
nosocomial infections in the united
states with an associated high mortality
burden
the cdc defines cre as an organism
resistant to at least one carbapenem
antibiotic or producing a karbapanama's
enzyme
because carbapenem resistance can be due
to various different mechanisms
detection of the presence of a
carbopanimase by molecular methods is
important
in the united states at the present time
roughly fifty percent of all cie
isolates other are covered panama's
producers
mostly harboring kpc
please note that the rates of cre and
cpe organisms vary by geographic region
and type of enzyme listed here are some
numbers for different uh
world regions like europe and asia
pacific
now regulatory agencies such as clsi and
ucast provide guidance regarding the
detection of public animations by
various laboratory test methods as well
as for interpretation of results
in general two types of test methods are
available genotypic detection tests and
phenotypic phenotypic detection tests
phenotypic tests such as the
aforementioned multiplex panels are
specific assays to detect the presence
of known carbopnea streams such as kpc
ndm and others
phenotypic tests have been used for some
longer time now and are either growth
based of our chemical methods phenotypic
methods are based on the expression of a
any carbopanimase enzyme during
bacterial growth and culture
the most recent idsa guidelines for the
treatment of cre are based on whether
the mechanism of resistance has been
identified or not
preferred and alternative treatment
options are based on the site of
infection specifically urinary tract
versus other sites furthermore for
treatment of infections outside the
urinary urinary tract the type of
carbapanamasus detected matters as well
this regard cephtacity av batten
homeropannon vaporbathin or
hemipenumvalibantim are preferred for
kpc producing pathogens whereas
cephtazine av bacterium in combination
with astrinam or safiderocal as
monotherapy are preferred for ndm
producing cre pathogens
going back to
the case two that we were discussing i
want to emphasize here that the workup
of apal specimen in immunocompromised
patients
perhaps like this patient with program
19 is rather complex
oftentimes additional cultures for fungi
and mycobacteria and other ancillary
tests will be performed depending on the
epidemiologic and individual patient
circumstances
i would also like to highlight that some
laboratories might utilize a molecular
multiplex pneumonia pathogen panel such
as the biofire panel for workup of a bal
specimen
such panels include targets for bacteria
and viruses as well as a limited number
of resistance genes for detection of a
primary source specimen
however a detected resistant stream
would not be directly linked to a
specific pathogen and this is
specifically problematic if multiple
pathogens are present in a clinical
specimen
in this specific case shown here such
panel was not used
the use of the acute amr panel would
have provided various benefits in the
management of this patient's illness in
this case
first the respective resistance genes
specifically the kpc gene would have
been reported rapidly and allowed for
tailored and more appropriate
antimicrobial therapy at least one day
sooner
in addition using the panel for each of
the pathogens that were isolated in this
patient's bal specimen would have
allowed for selecting an antibiotic that
covered both pathogens rather than using
multiple antimicrobial agents
furthermore the inclusion of additional
non-beta-lactam resistance markers on
the panel would have been helpful as the
patient was also empirically started on
tobramycin as per the
ventilator-associated pneumonia protocol
to summarize this case let's review the
impact of the intuitive amr panel on the
management of this patient's antibiotic
therapy
the patient was diagnosed with a
ventilator associated ammonia and
empiric therapy was started with
vancomycin pipracial and taser bacteria
if the equities panel had been used the
respective resistance genes for both
pathogens have been known on day two
when the patient would have been
switched to maritime and vapor vacuum
according to the treatment guidelines
vancomycin was indeed discontinued as no
brain positive organisms were identified
phenotypic susceptibility test results
were available on the following days
however ast results for the additional
antimicrobial agents such as ceftazidime
av bacterium would have also been
available at least one day earlier
now i will turn it back to dr simner for
the next clinical case
so i'm going to take finish off with
case number three
this is a 35 year old male electric
electrician with no significant past
medical history presented to medical
care after an accidental electrocution
he experienced 25 total body surface
area third and fourth degree burns
the burn wounds of the skull were
complicated by a soft tissue defect in
the left periodo temporal region which
is highlighted in the image here the
patient underwent excision and
debridement of the scalp wounds
he subsequently developed fevers and a
purulent material was identified at the
site the fluid was drained and sent for
aerobic and anaerobic cultures the
patient was started empirically on
marropenum gentamicin and vancomycin
the gram stain of results
from the drainage revealed a heavy pmns
and a gram-negative bacilli
which uh on the following day from solid
media we were able to detect a
non-lactose fermenting oxidase positive
ground negative bacilli which was
ultimately identified as pseudomonas
originosa based off of the ground stain
and culture growth with the absence of
any gram-positive organisms they were
able to discontinue vancomycin at this
point
so what if we would have performed the
cutis amr gene panel uh from the the
recovered isolate on this patient well
we would have detected a per producing
um
pseudomonas originosa where per is a
beta lactamase gene which i'll go over
in a little bit
that provides resistance or is
associated with
not susceptible results to the
carbopenems based off of the cutis panel
it also detected resistance genes
associated with
and
aminoglycosides
a mutant which was associated with
fluoroquinolone resistance
based on this panel result we could
hypothesize based off of the unlikely
activity of traditional lactime agents
and resistance to the fluoroquinolones
that we're dealing with a difficult to
treat pseudomonas originosa
before we get into treatment guidelines
let's cover what per what a what per is
so per is a pseudomonas extended
resistance enzyme that was first
described in 1993 and classified as an
extended spectrum beta-lactamase it
provides resistance to penicillins
narrow and extended spectrum
cephalosporins monobactams um it's
inhibited by clavulani but not by
tazobactam and this becomes important
later
the beta lactam resistance mechanisms in
pseudomonas originals are complex
and
multiple mechanisms can mediate
resistance to the beta lactams whether
those be some of the chromosomal
beta-lactamase genes such as oxa 50
which is the narrow spectrum oxilanes
or the inducible amc the pdc
cephalosporinase that can be induced in
this bug due to the presence of
particular beta-lactama beta-lactam
agents or due to the production of
efflux pumps or poorer mutations in
addition to the ability to acquire
plasma immediate and beta-lactamase
genes such as esbls apses or
carbapenemeses
however pseudomonas originosa can turn
these on or off based off of different
selective pressures and the combination
of these mechanisms is what provides the
variable beta lactam susceptibility
profiles that we encounter with
pseudomonas originals that clinically in
the lab
so for the cutest gene panel the
detection of per is associated with not
susceptible results to carbopenems and
this is likely due to the isolates that
they tested during the trial
not only produce per but a combination
of other mechanisms leading to
carbopenum resistance and associated
with uh not susceptible results when
detected by this panel
and so
so now we have this per producing
defined as a difficult to treat
pseudomonas so what are the treatment
guidelines for uh such such an infection
so this would be an infection outside of
the urinary tract
and so the preferred agents would be
septualizing tazobactem
mavibactam or
imapenomeralbactem an alternative
therapy listed is cephedaricol
however the problem here is that
we know that per producing pseudomonas
isolates
do not respond to cephtolozaine
tazobactem because the per enzyme
hydrolyzes cephtolozane
and is not inhibited by tethobactem so
it has no activity
so the additional understanding of what
is the mechanism
meat-eating beta-lactam resistance in
this particular case is very helpful
because treatment guidelines are telling
us to go to these agents but knowing
it's a per-producing pseudomonas we
realize that subtotalizing taseobacter
is not an option that should be
considered in this case um ceptazity
mavibactam has been reported to be
associated with resistance when with per
producing isolates and this is likely
due to the combination of per and other
mechanisms of resistance
and similarly with imipenem royal
bacterium and so fitter call although
the reports so far listed as being
stable with these enzymes there are
reports of elevated mic to these new new
drugs and these are newer drugs and so
more data is really required to
understand the activity and spectrum
with per producing isolates
so what impact could have the acute amr
gene panel had what's the significance
in this case well it would allow us to
more it allowed us to more rapidly
detect a difficult to treat pseudomonas
originosa
and idsa treatment guidelines suggest
that novel beta-lactam combination
agents plus or minus aminoglycosides
empirically
should be considered however because we
detected a per-producing pseudomonas
that um the team could would have
probably considered transitioning to
safadaricol based on the literature that
per producing isolates are resistant to
septology and tazobactam and may be
resistant to cephtacity mappy bacterium
if there's other mechanisms playing a
role in resistance here
the inclusion of the jar a mutant on
this panel and detection in this
particular case allows clinicians and
laboratorians to define the isolate as a
probable
difficult to treat isolate to further
guide therapy
and the inclusion of the aminoglycoside
markers
allowed
can allow clinicians to discontinue
nephrotoxic aminoglycoside agents
earlier in this case rather than having
to wait to phenotypic asts to detect
aminoglycoside resistance
so overall the patient was started
empirically on maripenum and gentamicin
and vancomycin
so based off of the gram stain and
culture growth and identification of
pseudomonas vancomycin could be
discontinued from the same day in
parallel or
after maldi id the cutis amr panel could
have been set up and within 2.5 hours we
could have potentially defined this
isolate as a difficult to treat isolate
and because it harbored the per enzyme
per gene i should say
they would have considered starting
to fitter call and discontinued
gentamicin as well in this case because
of the
detection of the additional
aminoglycoside resistance genes
and they would ultimately waited until
the phenotypic ast results were
available to make final treatment
decisions because of the difficult to
treat nature of this isolate and the
resistance markers detected
so with that i'm going to pass it back
to dr riedel to wrap up
now that we discussed the potential
clinical utility of the acuteos amr
panel
i would like to return to the mr problem
with which represents a global public
health emergency of increasing magnitude
as i described in more detail at the
beginning of today's presentation
while newer antimicrobial agents and
treatment guidelines help address the
growing amr problem and specific
organisms such guidelines inevitably
place pressure on laboratories to
provide the timely and necessary
diagnostic support with molecular test
methods
however some caveats need to be
considered here
when phenotypic susceptibility test
results don't match earlier genotypic
test results like gene detections
laboratories must develop ways to
reconcile such discrepancies
furthermore we must understand that the
absence of resistance genes does not
necessarily mean that the organism is
susceptible to the respective antibiotic
lastly as mentioned earlier newer
regulatory standards will require
laboratories to link resistant genes
detected by molecular methods to the
respective organism identified in the
specimen and culture
as one of the clinical cases addressed a
patient who was diagnosed with fast kobe
2 i want to highlight the importance
that some viral respiratory infections
can be complicated by secondary
bacterial pneumonias
during the past two years most of our
efforts in laboratory and clinical
medicine have been directed toward the
corvit-19 pandemic
at the same time however antibiotic
utilization increased in many hospitals
at the same time hospital onset
infections due to amr pathogens in cova
patients have significantly increased
and are now higher compared to similar
infections in patients with influenza
during prior years
in some instances rates have increased
by as much as 134 percent
while probit 19 has taken center stage
for the past two years i want to
emphasize here that covet 19 and amr are
parallel and interacting health
emergencies
and when the kovit 19 pandemic will
hopefully and eventually be resolved at
some point the amr pandemic will
certainly continue and represent a
long-term problem
in this regard i would now like to
emphasize fear the importance of using
rapid and more comprehensive amr
diagnostic panel testing in clinical
laboratory practice
the acuitous amr panel has several
advantages over the other currently
available molecular test methods
amr detection and linkage to a
particular organism is important
turnaround time of 2.5 hours and an
approximately 30 minute hands-on time is
reasonably short
and as more comprehensive paramore this
panel includes non-beta-lactam amr genes
including those what might be considered
salvage therapy antibiotics such as
cholister
the acuitous amr panel is useful in
direct clinical patient care as well as
in support of hospital infection control
and epidemiology programs to identify
and track amr
pathogens in hospitals as well as state
laboratories
with that i would like to conclude here
that the field of amr is dynamic and
rapidly evolving
treatment of antimicrobial resistant
infections especially those due to cre
espl producers and dtr pseudomonas
aeruginosa continued to challenge
physicians and clinicians
now rapid molecular diagnostic tests
such as the acute amr panel can provide
valuable information to guide approach
to antimicrobial treatment and shortened
turnaround time to implementing
appropriate therapy
further use and additional studies with
the acute amr panel will help to better
understand the impact on patient care
antimicrobial stewardship hospital
infection control interventions and amr
development
this concludes the presentation and we
would like to thank you for your time
and attention and i'm turning it over
now to our moderator for the questions
and answers
thank you dr riedel dr simner for your
informative presentation
we will now start the live q a portion
of the webinar
if you have a question you'd like to ask
please do so now just click on the ask a
question box located on the far left of
your screen we'll answer as many of your
questions as we have time for
let's get started our first question is
for dr simner
would the acuitous panel be able to
detect resistance to all known
antibiotics or is it currently limited
to a certain number of antibiotics
thank you mary and thank you everyone
for your attention
so that's a good question so the cutest
amr panel detects 28 antimicrobial
resistance genes
and those genes are associated with up
to nine classes or subclasses of
antimicrobials so in short it does not
detect all
amr genes nor is it able to to predict
or associate resistance with all
antibiotics
but that being said it is the broadest
amr panel uh currently available
and um but a good another thing to point
out is that the detection of amr genes
and the association with not susceptible
results will vary based off of the
organism being identified
thank you
our next question is for dr riedel
besides the beta lactamases how will all
the other genes on the panel help guide
therapy
uh
thank you
this is this is an excellent question
and i think dr simmond i presented two
cases that hopefully help illustrate
this a little bit having actually
additional genes available
on this panel and as we we highlighted
sometimes either for step-down therapy
or for combination therapy
or salvage therapy
um some of the agents that that are
available the antibiotic classes that
are on this panel like the polymixons or
the like uh the floquinolons
or the sulfonamides trimester from sofa
methoxazole
are actually important antimicrobial
agents and it is important for
clinicians to know earlier in in order
to decide whether these are even
possible options for step-down therapy
or
the combination therapy so i think that
this adds certainly valuable information
in conjunction with the
genes for the beta-lactam group of
antimicrobials
thank you
our next question is for dr simner
how would a lab report the result from
the acuitous amr gene panel to
clinicians
well that's a great question and
unfortunately i might not have the most
satisfying answer but i could give you a
little bit of guidance on how to
approach this
so um
the cutest amr gene panel and results is
complex because you have 28 different
amr genes and then association with not
susceptible with antimicrobial agents
which will vary by by bug right so this
is even more complex than even some of
our standard panels that we have in the
lab um so it's important this is my my
answer is that it's important that you
work with
your stewardship team your infection
control team and if that if you're not
unsure who that is at your institution
figure it out or also or reach out to a
clinical champion that you're close with
to help you try to convey these results
in the most appropriate way to hope to
beneficially impact patient care because
we all know that these results are
complex it's even complex for you know
some of us sometimes to understand what
are all the resistance genes how are
they associated so it is going to be key
that you work with your clinical team to
work on how to report these so that
they're conveyed appropriately to
patient-facing clinicians so that they
can
interpret these complex results in terms
of patient care
and in line with some of the antibiotic
treatment guidelines that you may have
at your individual institution
thank you our next question is again for
dr simner phenotype is still important
the presence of amr gene is not 100
equivalent to resistance can you address
this caveat
yeah i think um
yes so phenotypic ast results are kind
of the standard
clinicians you know are very um
used to receiving those results over the
years
and know how to interpret these so i
think this comes back to the previous
question is how are you reporting these
results
to your clinical team so that the
results are interpreted appropriately
and so yes the detection of a resistance
gene does not always correlate with
resistance
that being said the detection is helpful
for clinical teams to understand that it
is present even sometimes when
phenotypically it's not
if we don't see the associated phenotype
in certain cases when we see those
discordants it's
currently recommended to take um a
conservative approach and almost report
your phenotype consistent with the
detection of that amr because there is
the probability of there's a possibility
that it can then be induced or expressed
leading to further resistance and so
the detection of those amr genes are can
be particularly helpful and then the
second point here is that um as i
mentioned the phenotype i cannot i
cannot
you know express how important it is but
now with some of our treatment
guidelines as dr riedel and i uh worked
through these cases demonstrated that
knowing the mechanisms mediating the
feta phenotype is also very helpful
because depending on that mechanism
treatment guidance may vary
thank you
our next question is for dr riedel
do you suggest restricting use of the
acuitous panel to certain culture types
wounds versus blood versus respiratory
etc
well this is an excellent question
um and uh
you know first first i think i'd like to
highlight that the this panel is
performed on bacterial isolates and
actually not directly from the specimen
which is a striking difference to some
of the other
tests that dr simm and i highlighted in
some of our cases here so by using it on
a particular microorganism or the ones
that are
highlighted
for the
for the organisms to which these 28 gene
targets apply
basically do not restrict the use of
this parameter to a particular isolate
from a very specific
specimen type so i think
i i would i would recommend to um
to
[Music]
laboratories to again work with
their local providers
to identify since we're talking
resistance the utilization to
specimens that come from patients in
whom resistance is really a problem and
that it would be irrespective of wound
blood or respiratory specimen type but
rather the type of patient setting
icu versus non-icu what that is is a
resistance um
in
[Music]
expected to exist and i think the local
antibiograms or the entire
annual antimicrobial antibiograms with
respect to resistance rates particularly
would be also very helpful in kind of
guiding
the uh the best implementation of that
panel
thank you
it looks like we have time for one more
question and this goes to dr simner what
is the value of this panel with the
advent of
oh ngs another good question okay so um
first off i'm just gonna
say that uh in terms of ngs here i'm in
my response i'm gonna be referring to
the application of whole genome
sequencing which would be if you took
your cultured isolate and then whole
genome performed whole genome sequencing
on that recovered isolate
um it's gaining traction you know
going from the research realm into the
clinical realm now we're starting to see
whole genome sequencing applications in
the clinical microbiology lab which is
an exciting technology
whole genome sequencing allows you can
allow you to provide an organism
identification can detect all of the amr
genes present in that pathogen it can
look at virulence factors
it also could be helpful for outbreak
response
the detection of amr genes by whole
genome sequencing will be dependent on
your database that you apply for
detection
and but can detect a broader panel that
being said whole genome sequencing and
engine ngs as a whole are still very
complex methods requiring not only um
significant molecular expertise and
instrumentation in the lab but also bio
bioinformatic expertise to be able to
interpret those results so although
we're seeing some progress with these um
both in terms of
simplifying the methods and
bioinformatics programs uh we're we're
still for the most part not in a area of
applying these broadly across the
hospitals
in the u.s just due to the complexity of
the methods
so
the cutest amr on the other hand and the
turnaround time with whole genome
sequencing can be quite long
because
depending on the sequencing platform
you're using
so you need to take that into
consideration as well in terms of how
that potentially could impact patient
care in terms of turnaround times and
how it would compare to phenotypic
results etc
so from the cutest standpoint
the fact that it is semi-automated
method
that allows most of the methods to be
automated with minimal hands on time as
well as having an automated
platform to interpret the results really
allows us to
implement this clinically into the
clinical microbiology lab to
be a more
an alternative that might be ready for
prime time
that is ready for prime time over whole
genome sequencing where i think there's
so much potential don't get me wrong i
just think that i think for the average
clinical microbiology lab
the methods are still
too advanced both from a molecular and
bioinformatics standpoint
thus
some of these
semi-automated and automated amr panels
are like the acuitous are the things
that most labs will be turning to to try
to
broaden the spectrum of amr genes being
detected to help guide clinical care
great well thank you again dr riedel dr
simner for your time today and your
important research
we would also like to thank lab roots
and our sponsor for underwriting today's
educational webcast
before we go i'd like to thank the
audience for joining us today and for
their interesting questions
questions we did not have time for today
and those submitted during the on-demand
period will be addressed by the speaker
via the contact information you provided
at the time of registration
this webcast can be viewed on demand lab
routes will alert you via email when
it's available for replay we encourage
you to share that email with your
colleagues who may have missed today's
live event
until next time goodbye
you